hey guys Rob here and I'm joined by Adam
bottie of Konami we're gonna be talking
about the latest installment in Pro
Evolution Soccer PES 2016 the game will
be released and mark the 20th
anniversary for the series and Adam is
going to be talking to us about the new
features and additions to the game
absolutely yeah and I mean I think one
of the big key things for pairs as we
improve everything like the visuals the
modes and animation what makes the pairs
pairs and separates it from everything
and every year is the gameplay and the
focus for us is to keep developing on
that keep making a statement with how
you play the game making sure it's
recreating everything and keeping it fun
for you as well one of the you know one
of the key features for us has been the
player control keeping it super
responsive I think it's been a number of
years now where PES has hasn't been
performing the best and last year was a
was a huge change and that's because we
focused in the gameplay and a lot of
that was down to emulating some of the
key features of the older games you
mentioned the anniversary and how we had
some great titles back in the day and a
lot of that was based on feel and the
responsiveness so what we've done is
we've really focused on player control
you know bringing in you know superstars
like Neymar and as you control and
dribble with him let's just drill down
vicked
let's just drill down on that player
control so so tell us in terms of actual
gameplay how is that improved and what
new additions are you bringing yeah
gameplay absolutely so the player
controlled going forward has been really
improved to give you the feeling that
you're always in control it's never out
of your control you know the animations
don't lock you never feel frustrated
when you when you press the button or
the there stick your player moves or
does an action straight away and that's
going all the fluid base it's super
fluid yes and then we we get a lot of
help from from the AI with that as well
we've got some new advanced AI where
it's about making a player never feeling
like they need to trigger a run so
players are moving into space all the
time and they're reacting to space
you're right back or Pusser inside and
then move off the ball naturally and
things like that but what actually
balanced that as well with the gameplay
what we've done is we've brought in a
brand new collision system for para it's
never never actually had one before so
last year it was it was quite awkward
and you did get a lot of locking
animations now it's calculated on the
fly so where you're hit sometimes you
don't need to go down and they're
playable will continue or if you or if
he if he does go down and the ball is
there to sort of be begotten again he
will get faster and right
go and get just canned animations is a
bit more bit more organic I suppose
absolutely and and actually extends into
the aerial battles that we've brought in
as well so what happens is is let's just
say you've got a really big guy in a
small guy let's just say Mertesacker
against ever won anything but at the
same time it might not be ever as
priority to win the ball so because of
the new collision systems if you know
you're not gonna win it maybe it's about
putting the guy off and shoving him as
he's going up for the header to make
sure he misses it or it's not on target
or where he wants to go I want to know
from you what you think makes the games
stand out what what makes the game
unique there's a lot of competition and
in terms of football games yeah well
there is one major competitor of course
of course yeah is that like a long-term
plan in place there is it are you
looking more towards the future because
obviously you can't change the market
you can't change the rival you can't
overcome FIFA in a single year you know
it's gonna take a long time for everyone
to understand the place is really great
again yeah is that what is that it do
you have a long-term plan yeah I think
the key thing for us is I mean I mean
some of the Fox engine our long-term
plan can can go on for years I mean
engine which adapts year on year we're
still playing catch-up because because
the engine is evolving while we're
working on pairs and it's a fantastic
thing so that secures our future in one
instance but you're absolutely right one
thing that we can't do is create one or
two games anymore and think that we've
convinced people we have to prove it's
not a fluke you know we have to keep
producing gear one year and there is a
long term plan when it when it went when
it comes to the gameplay the visuals the
mode and and what we're doing a really
important thing that I'd say to
everybody is you know is that when PES
was seen as the best it was never the
best seller
so what's important for PES is it's it's
it's not perception and it's that
recognition that means a lot to us you
know we don't have all the licenses and
therefore we don't have the bigger teams
and therefore we don't have the
overheads we'll it has to be better
that's that's that's nothing you can win
on right exactly and how we win is on
the things that we can control yeah we
can't control licenses even though we've
you know cards yeah exactly
but we can't control the quality of our
game and that's something that we'll
focus on well it's good that you've done
this at the start of the console cycle
because you know you've got ten years
remember when PES started ps2 yeah sorry
sorry a ps3 that was when we start
having a lot of problems yes weather
hazard dropped off that's right yeah all
the stakes again
yeah no completely yeah and you told my
licenses I think yeah do have actually I
think you have snagged one license
absolutely you have an exclusive
competition that will rights in a
competition
absolutely yeah just a few months ago we
we announced that we've refined UEFA
Champions League license for over three
years however just announced at Gamescom
huge big big deal we've just signed that
you way for Euro 2016 competition at the
first time ever I mean you've sort of
mentioned the competition it's been it's
been held by EA since its existence
first time now that we've managed to get
a big license I think it's a statement
you know yeah you know licenses are
something that as I mentioned that we
can't control but I want everyone to
know that as soon as something comes up
we're gonna go for it well thank you
ever so much for that a demand for more
analysis on pro Evolution Soccer 2016
stay tuned to gain spot